what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about perhaps the single most
interesting question in all of attack on
Titan who is the biggest bad guy the
ultimate evil in the ruthless and
merciless world of attack on Titan in
most anime and manga the villains are
pretty obvious and seven deadly sins
it's the demon king in one punch man
it's the monster association in MHA the
villains literally called themselves the
league of villains and in black clover
it's the animation studio but an attack
on Titan things are much less clear and
that is also what makes attack on Titan
so interesting so today I will delve
deep into the question of who will be
the final villain and the ultimate evil
in attack on Titan if you enjoy the
attack on Titan content on this channel
you want to see more you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell you can
also follow us on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar for all the latest news
and updates and finally this video will
contain manga spoilers we will be
dealing with the very latest
developments in the attack on Titan
stories so please proceed with caution
you have been warned at the beginning of
attack on Titan the villains are pretty
obvious
the Titans these giant creatures are
literal monsters and their main hobby is
eating people so in terms of bad guys it
doesn't get any more obvious than that
however things become a lot more
complicated as we realize that the
protagonist of the story and the guy who
swore to kill all the Titans Eren Yeager
can actually transform into a Titan
himself for some unknown reason the very
idea that humans can become Titans
changes our perspective suddenly the
Titans are not just some strange
creatures who exist completely
separately from humans if a human can
become a Titan
even though Eren can turn back into a
human later the very nature of the
relationship between humans and Titans
is brought into question of course we
later learned that every single Titan
even the mindless Titans who roam around
aimlessly like big dumb sacs of flesh
were once human beings every Titan was
once a human who was turned into a Titan
against their will and as titans these
humans have virtually no control over
their actions they suddenly become
mindless beasts who devour human flesh
even though this is something they never
would have done as humans this
complicates the whole villain situation
even further yes the Titans as they are
right now are a menace and an
existential threat to humans unless the
humans kill these Titans they will most
likely be killed themselves and killing
the Titans in self-defense is something
the humans behind the walls are forced
to do at the same time killing a Titan
is the same as killing the innocent
human who had been turned into that
specific Titan against their own will so
even if you kill them out of
self-defense because you have to you
can't exactly be happy about it and
what's more we can't exactly consider
these regular Titans to be the ultimate
evil in attack on Titan because as
humans they were not evil they did not
choose to be turned into Titans and once
they were turned into Titans they became
mindless monsters simply following their
natural urge to consume humans a
mindless Titan attacking a human is no
more evil than a hungry wolf attacking a
chicken coop at the same time that we
are learning more about the Titans and
how they came to exist in the first
place we also learned that there are
some extremely evil humans behind the
walls
although these humans are not mindless
beasts and although they enjoy all the
benefits of human intelligence reason
and emotion these humans choose to do
terrible things to other humans look no
further than the corrupt government
behind the walls and the first interior
squad who have no problem brutally
torturing and killing people who ask too
many questions or criticize the king and
his government in many ways we can argue
that these humans humans like Kenny and
the people who killed our man's parents
Irwin's father and pastor Nick are
bigger monsters than the mindless Titans
the Titans are just following their
natural urges and instincts like a wild
animal but the humans have the ability
to think rationally they have a choice
and they still choose to harm their own
fellow human beings behind the walls we
have all types of humans living together
and facing the threat of the Titans
together we have innocent and good
people we have people like aaron and
levi who are emotionally
scarred and traumatized but are trying
to do the right thing we have people
like Arman who dream of a more peaceful
world and we have people who only want
power and control like members of the
ruling regime this is very similar to
our own world where we also have people
of all varieties living and surviving
together mine is the threat of the
Titans but then we have the Titan
shifters Eren is not the only human who
can become a Titan and then turn back in
fact we eventually learned that Annie
Reiner and Bertolt are also humans who
can become Titans
and we learned that they were the ones
who broke through wall Maria and
willingly brought all the Titans in
resulting in the deaths of thousands of
people based just on this it is easy to
hate Annie Reiner and Bertolt and to see
them as true monsters and it's true that
the three of them did something that
cannot and should not be forgiven but
the more do we learn about them the more
their status as monstrous villains
collapses before our eyes through their
interaction with the other recruits and
with each other we see that Annie Reiner
and Bertolt are very human they have
doubts misgivings regrets and a guilty
conscience about what they did we
quickly get the hint that the three of
them are not necessarily doing what they
chose to do but rather they appear to be
doing something that has been thrust
upon them by someone else as the story
progresses we meet the beast Titan
another Titan shifter and eventually we
learned the truth about Annie bertolt
Reiner and where they really come from
the three of them come from beyond the
walls and they grew up in a country that
discriminated against them and treated
them like inferior and dangerous people
for no other reason than the fact that
they were born as ldiots they spent
their childhood being indoctrinated by
male propaganda which tried to convince
them that all LD ins are inherently evil
and that the only way for them to atone
for the sins of their kind is to help
Marly destroy the LD ins on the island
they entered the merlion warrior program
which was designed in order to recruit
LD ins who would be willing to fight for
Marlay as Titan shifters because only LD
ants could become Titans Marly had to
rely on LD ins to compete with each
other in order to determine who should
Herot one of the titan shifter powers
the reward for LD ins who passed the
warrior program and succeeded in
inheriting one of the titan shifter
powers was honorary male and citizenship
for themselves and their families which
meant that their families could finally
stop living in horrible conditions and
could actually afford food medicine and
other basic necessities when Annie
Bertolt and Reiner came to the island of
paradise they truly believed that they
were not going to be hurting people but
rather evil Devils who are a threat to
the entire world well it's likely that
Annie didn't feel this way and that she
saw through Marlin propaganda but Reiner
definitely felt for these lies at first
it is only after the three shifters
infiltrated the walls and came to
realize that the people behind the walls
were just normal people like everyone
else that Reiner Annie and Berthold
could be said to have had a choice at
this point
they could have abandoned their mission
because they realized that they were
being asked to kill innocent people or
they could have continued abandoning the
mission would have likely caused
problems for their families back in
Marlay but I believe that abandoning the
mission after realizing what the people
behind the walls were really like would
have been the right thing to do
continuing to follow Marla's orders
after realizing that the LD ins were not
Devils just normal people like everyone
else was a choice and I believe that it
was the wrong choice
Annie Reiner and Bertolt can be
legitimately criticized for continuing
on with the mission even after spending
years in the 104th training corps and
befriending so many LD ends on the
island but the fact that the three of
them did have regrets and in some cases
these regrets led to the development of
serious and lasting mental problems
proves that Reiner Annie and Bertolt are
not just evil monsters they are not
ruthless villains in spite of their
immoral actions they are human beings
who found themselves in a difficult and
tragic situation and who made some bad
choices in my opinion and that brings us
to the real evil behind the entire
mission to infiltrate the walls the
marlins
in many ways the marlins and especially
their government and military are the
closest thing that we have to an
outright villain in attack on titan the
way that the Marlins treat the LD ins is
inexcusable
the way that they expect innocent LD ins
to continuously pay for the supposed
sins of their ancient ancestors is
ludicrous we are not sure how much of
the history that Marly claims is true is
fact and how much is fiction but
regardless of what happened in the past
the way that Marlins treat the
audience's inhumane and unjustifiable
there are summer lands like general Theo
McGrath who are more tolerant towards
ldiots but on the whole we have seen
everyone from members of the military
and security forces to ordinary janitors
on the streets abusing LD ins including
LD and children not only that but
despite hating the audience the Marlins
are still not above using LD ins and
their ability to transform into Titans
as a weapon against rival nations in
fact Marla has used both the Titan
shifter powers and the power of the
mindless Titans to become a great
military power and to subjugate other
nations to its rule so to put it simply
kamar lay seriously
but as much as I hate the government
military and security forces of Marlay
for being opportunistic militaristic
supremacists we have to acknowledge that
even Marlay has
innocent civilians including children so
even if war against them is just we have
to remember that every war will result
in civilian casualties also I would love
to say that Marlins are so obviously the
bad guys that it's unrealistic for them
to ever exist in the real world but
sadly all we need to do is look back to
World War Two and we will see that a
regime as insane and evil as Marlay is
not just fiction aside from the
government of Marlay being clear
villains in my opinion recent chapters
of the manga have forced us to
repeatedly reevaluate the role of aaron
and his half-brother Zeke in the attack
on Titan story Aaron started out as the
protagonist and Zeke started out as a
villain however in recent chapters Aaron
and Zeke have teamed up and their goal
is supposedly to carry out Zeke's master
plan although I'm not sure that Aaron
will ultimately go along with Zeke's
insane plan but let's talk about Aaron
first after realizing the truth about
the outside world Aaron had a choice he
could stay on paradies and wait from our
lands to keep attacking the island until
eventually Marley's modern technology
and remaining titan powers destroyed
every L
on the island or he could do something
to strike back against the enemy and
defend the island Aaron decided on the
latter he infiltrated Marlay by
pretending to be a wounded veteran and
he established contact with his
half-brother Zeke who was also plotting
against Marley together they launched an
attack on the burial captured the
Warhammer Titan power and with the help
of armen's colossal titan they destroyed
a large chunk of Marley's army however
in the process of capturing the
Warhammer Titan a lot of innocent people
including LD ins were killed in Lipari
oh these casualties were a direct result
of Aaron's decision not to sit back and
to take the war to the enemy so this is
a burden that he now must bear on his
shoulders on top of that after consuming
the Warhammer Titan Aaron's personality
changed with three Titan powers inside
of him Aaron's mine is filled with the
memories of hundreds of previous Titan
shifters and he has recently begun to
appear mentally unstable and if that
wasn't enough as he has gotten closer to
Zeke Aaron has deliberately distanced
himself from his closest friends
including Mikasa and Armin Aaron
insulted Mikasa by insinuating that she
only defends him because her Ackerman
jeans are biologically programmed to do
it and when Armin protested against
Aaron's behavior Aaron physically
assaulted Armin all of this has raised
questions about whether Aaron has come
full circle and become the embodiment of
the famous saying from The Dark Knight
you either die a hero or live long
enough to see yourself become the
villain and once we learned what Zeke's
ultimate plan actually is if Aaron
really supports it then it isn't hard to
make the argument that Aaron has become
the villain now let's look at Zeke as we
know Zeke had a very tough childhood
because his father intended to use him
as nothing more than a tool to help the
LDN restoration is to destroy Marlay and
at a very young age Zeke was forced to
betray his own parents to the
authorities in order to save his own
life and the lives of his grandparents
after that Zeke appeared to be a loyal
male a warrior serving them as the Beast
Titan shifter but it turns out later
that Zeke's ultimate plan was to betray
Marlay in order to get his hands on the
founding titan power but the reason it's
equal
once the founding tightened power is not
to save his own people the audience but
rather to euthanize them back when he
was still training to become the Beast
Titan Zeke learned from his mentor Tom
Xavier that whoever possessed the
founding Titan power could change not
only the memories of all LD ins but also
their biological makeup by this point
Zeke had decided that the life on LDN
was nothing but suffering and that their
ability to turn into titans would always
make them pariahs among the other
nations of the world for this reason
Zeke decided that the best thing for the
audience is to simply go extinct he
decided to use the founding Titan power
to make all LD and sterile so that this
generation of LD ends would become the
very last generation but because Zeke
has royal blood
if he tried to take the founder for
himself he would be overtaken by the
145th king's pacifist ideology so he
decided that he must work together with
Aaron instead because Aaron possesses
the founding Titan power without having
royal blood now even though I can relate
to the struggle and hardships that Zeke
had to go through as a child both at the
hands of his parents and at the hands of
the Marlon regime I cannot support his
plan as I said before the audience were
alive today did not choose to be born
with the power to turn into Titans and
they are not responsible for the alleged
sins of their ancestors
Zeke's idea that all LD ends deserve to
simply die off is no better than the
oppressive and discriminatory believes
that the Marlins have about ldiots and
this type of self-hatred that Zeke is
exhibiting is a good example of
internalized racism Zeke has witnessed
the audience being mistreated and
discriminated against all his life and
in his mind he has come to accept that
there is something wrong with the
audience in reality there is something
wrong with those individuals who choose
to abuse and discriminate against
innocent people the fault does not live
with the people who are being abused
so is Zeke a villain yes if this is
really his plan then I would call him a
villain albeit a villain who is a
traumatized and tortured soul we can all
understand how Zeke's traumatic life has
led him to do the things he has done
but just because we can understand that
his life was difficult doesn't mean that
we should support the genocide or plan
that he wants to implement
on his own people Zeke might have turned
against Marley but his plan is in line
with the wishes of the most viciously
aunty L D and Marlins it is ironic that
throughout his childhood Zeke suffered
discrimination at the hands of the
Marlins including being forced to wear a
special armband when in public so that
everyone would know that he was LD and
these armbands are part of the reason
why Zeke faced abuse and discrimination
on a daily basis from aggressive Marlins
for instance in Chapter 114 we see an
instance when a young Zeke and his
parents were out on a rooftop of a
building overlooking the barrio just
talking and enjoying the view and then
mr lay and janitor sees their arm bends
he instantly attacks them throwing water
all over them and insulting them he
demands to know how these descendents of
the devil would dare to reproduce and
have more children
the janitor believed that the LD ins
were inherently evil this part of the
devil and that they shouldn't be allowed
to even have children this was a deeply
traumatizing experience for Zeke and yet
as an adult he is essentially carrying
out the wishes of that Marley and
janitor to make the irony complete after
Zeke tainted some wine with his spinal
fluid so that key members of the survey
corps on paradise would turn into Titans
as soon as he screamed those LD ins who
consumed the wine were required to wear
black armbands to differentiate them
from those who didn't drink the wine how
sad and ironic that after living through
the cruel treatment that the audience
faced in Marley including being forced
to wear armbands to prove that they are
different from everyone else
Zeke decided to pursue a plan that the
very Marlins who abused him and his
family would have wholeheartedly
supported and because of Zeke other LD
ins were forced to wear armbands in
order to be differentiated from their
fellow human beings
so yes Zeke is a villain but he is a
villain who was created by the
traumatizing and abusive circumstances
of his life the fact that he is the
beast Titan and the fact that he has a
plan that I would consider villainous
suggests that Zeke is the real monster
in attack on Titan although he is a
monster of maar león and grisha's making
the thing that differentiates human from
wild beasts and from the mindless Titans
is their ability to choose the right
path in life but Zeke wants to take that
choice away
from his own people by forcing them
never to reproduce again and this is so
similar to the Marlins taking away so
many basic human choices and freedoms
from the ldiots the real question is
what will Eren do now personally I agree
with Armin
I think Aaron is pretending to go along
with Zeek because he needs his help
especially since Zeke has royal blood
which allows Aaron to harness the power
of the founding Titan but ultimately I
believe that Aaron will reject Zeke's
euthanasia plan and I believe that he
will do his best to find a solution that
will allow the LD ins to coexist with
the other nations ironically the real
monsters an attack on Titan are not the
giant man-eating Titans the real
monsters and villains are humans like
the Malayan military and government or
members of the first interior squad who
are willing to torture and kill innocent
people a good illustration of this fact
is the character development of Gabi who
is an LDN that was completely
brainwashed by Marlin propaganda and
someone who genuinely believed that the
LDN zone parodies were all Devils and
that everything would be fine in the
world if not for them Gabi has
infuriated so many fans by her behavior
and actions towards her own people
all because of Marla's insidious and
vile propaganda
however in chapter 118 even Gabi finally
comes to the realization that there were
never any Devils on the island of
parodies only humans just like in Marley
and just like everywhere else in the
world but that doesn't mean that there
aren't any villains on the island it
just means that the true villains are
not monsters or Devils they are humans
this is the case on parodies in Marley
and everywhere else including our own
world the real monster in attack on
Titan is the human monster the monsters
are those individuals who haven't been
turned into mindless Titans those who
can still use their ability to think
rationally to think critically and to
empathize with fellow human beings but
they choose not to this is the key point
the real monsters are those who have a
choice
but still choose to do the evil immoral
thing the mindless Titans don't have a
real choice they are driven by natural
urges
nothing more sergeant-major grouse and
other Marlins like him do have a choice
Zeke does have a choice Aaron will have
a choice and I honestly hope that he
makes the right one our choices is what
distinguishes us from wild beasts and
making the conscious choice to do a
terrible thing is what makes you a
terrible person making the conscious
choice to act like a monster is what
makes you a monster and our own human
history tells us that far too often
humans have made that very choice but
let me know what you guys think who will
be the final villain in attack on titan
and what choice do you think that aaron
will make in the end will he side with
Zeke or will he ultimately choose to
side with Arman and Mikasa let me know
down in the comments I'd love to hear
your thoughts if you enjoyed the attack
on titan content on this channel and you
want to see more you can leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to anime
uproar please don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell a huge
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for supporting our work I want
to give a special thank you to our pro
hero to your patrons including the one
and only Gilgamesh chubs is the man and
nothing but a fan and another huge thank
you to our the one tier patrons the ones
who stand above all other clans
including baby ray ace in grata a
lowland Adam Maddy Mac and Michael
called that on if you guys feel that our
content provides value for you and you
want to support more be sure to check
out our patreon link in the description
even donating a single dollar will give
you access to our anime up for patron
exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching I really appreciate
it and until next time see our space
cowboys
[Music]